[Music]
[Applause]
now
jesse palmer is a college football
analyst for the mothership
and he'll be part of espn's live studio
coverage surrounding
week 16 action sunday's college football
playoff selection day the college
football playoff selection show
noon eastern this sunday on espn jesse
thanks for taking time out to join us
let me start with justin herbert how did
he go from what he was at oregon to what
he is now with the chargers
yeah dan i mean i've been really
impressed what i've seen from justin in
his rookie season i think to me more
than anything it's just been ball
location i think that was my biggest
question for justin herbert coming out
of oregon where
you know you knew he had size and you
knew he had tremendous arm talent but
there were times
on throws ball location wasn't exactly
precise and there were times
on outbreaking routes on the sideline
where he'd miss a guy maybe leave it a
little bit inside
the play might have gotten broken up in
college but you'd watch that and say
well on sunday if you put that
a couple inches behind the receiver
that's a pick six
he hasn't had those ball location issues
his accuracy
has been spot on he's hitting guys in
the face mask
he's hitting guys in the numbers and
he's doing it while he's able to move
around in the pocket he's been throwing
under duress his deep ball accuracy has
been phenomenal
um just so impressed with justin herbert
because
listening to you in in a lot of other
people as well
it's pretty obvious anyone that's
watched them i think he's he's exceeded
the expectations by a long shot this
year and i was
we got to see marcus mariota again last
night and this is the
marcus mariota we saw at oregon and the
guy who really put pressure on the
defense
but when he was with tennessee he seemed
very tentative he didn't want to take
advantage of you know his weapons his
athleticism but we did see it last night
what do you
like is he a backup quarterback or do
you see him as a starting quarterback
no i mean at this point i think i i see
him more as a backup and a guy that
certainly can come in games and
potentially give a spark to an offense
and you're right i think during
his early career in tennessee just
didn't seem to put it together
he was obviously you know in charge of a
chip kelly offense at oregon that really
capitalized on his athleticism
and zone reads and rpos and still at a
time where that was kind of in the
forefront
cutting edge offense at the collegiate
level
obviously moving to tennessee a much
more complex offense
and he just never seemed to fully grasp
that and they were never fully able to
take advantage of his talents after
being the second overall pick so
he's a guy that i certainly see having a
very long career and and hopefully for
him he'll get another opportunity down
the road but
you know at this point um i think it's
it's more likely at least that he he's a
career backup that gets chances to get
in games and play and certainly still
capable of winning a lot of games
we had nick saban on yesterday and he
brought up something interesting about
recruiting and how it's changed and he
said
these kids come in and think they're
starting right away
and they haven't been told no or they
haven't been criticized
and he said you know there's an
adjustment there and you have social
media jesse
that expects you you're a five star hey
what's wrong with you
like there's a whole lot that goes into
going from high school to college and if
you're playing a high profile position
like quarterback
um he said that's that's been a big
challenge for me here
trying to talk how do you talk to
somebody who hasn't been talked to that
way by
an old school coach i think that's why
you're seeing so many transfers now in
college football it seems like a kid
shows up on campus
he's not starting right away and
immediately he's out the door
and he's looking for another opportunity
and it's not uncommon now to see guys
not just transfer one time
transfer two three sometimes even more
um you're right there's so much uh media
surrounding these players now kids are
they're committing to their schools on
national tv
sometimes kids are committing you know
early in high school middle school kids
now are getting offered and
everybody keeps telling them how great
they are and the reality is they get to
a program like in alabama where there's
you're not just getting the best players
in state or in the southeast you're
getting them from
all over the country everybody wants to
go play for a guy like nick saban
um and it takes a very tough-minded kid
now to come in a guy like mac jones
who you know still wanted to go to
school there even though jalen hurts was
there
even though a tuatanga low was there um
there were question marks surrounding
mack jones heading into this year only
had four starts they go out and get the
number one dual threat prospect in the
country and bryce young
and still mac jones has you know he he
just kind of buckles up and says okay i
got to earn this job
so you're right it's a totally different
mindset today
um that and it's so much harder today
for coaches to have to manage their
rosters based on how willing
and easy it is for kids now to transfer
simply because they're not getting the
playing time they expected early
should the heisman trophy come down to
the winner of alabama florida
uh i think so and you know i would still
give the edge right now to mac jones and
it really
for me goes beyond just being 10-0 and
being the number one ranked team in the
country and obviously max put up
fantastic numbers but dan i really think
if you've watched the games if you've
watched
if you watched mac jones play week in
week out he's just
playing the position at a different
level
it's not just accuracies and avoiding it
and avoiding interceptions
it's moving around the pocket it says
anticipation on throws he's getting hit
right in the chest he's got guys in his
lap and it's not affecting
his efficiency um i'm not saying mac
jones is
is the nfl um prospect that trevor
lawrence
is by by no stretch but i think you
could make the argument mac jones has
played better this year
and he's played more consistently
certainly on a weekend week out basis
kyle trask is completely shouldered not
just the florida gator offense but that
entire team
and for them to pull the upset against
florida he's gonna he's gonna have to
have another a plus type performance but
i think those two guys have sort of
separated themselves for the rest of the
pack
he's jesse palmer espn college football
analyst but
mac jones could be the heisman trophy
winner he's not the best player on his
own team
yeah you could make the argument devonte
smith yes uh you could make yeah i mean
there's a bunch of guys on defense that
are good too and they've got
a left tackle and leatherwood that's
really good naji harris is leading the
nation and rushing arts
that's that's the reality at uh that's
the reality at alabama you probably
could have said the same thing for danny
werfel when he won the heisman trophy at
florida
and you probably could say the same
thing maybe for matt leinart when he won
the heisman trophy
at usc yeah i don't think he was the
best
dorsey was up for the heisman trophy as
well
like it is strange where mac jones might
win it but
devante smith to me is the best player
on that team
and devonte smith might not be the best
receiver on that team jalen waddle might
be the best
you think he's better do you think he's
better
he only played four games it seemed like
he was catching a a bubble screen and
taking a 90 to the house every game and
the scary part for bama is they might
get him back in the playoff i don't know
like it would be funny to walk in that
locker room and really bring a bunch of
scouts and say okay just
just you know look at this clutter and
tell me who you think the best is
because
it's uh you know that that a lot of ways
probably explains why they're the number
one mac jones told me he said
the hardest throw is when the receiver's
wide open
as so as a former quarterback and saban
agreed
he said yes and saban i think played one
year at the position when he went to
college but
is that the hard throw the wide-open gun
yeah
yeah and it's harder for matt because i
feel like it happens a lot
steve sarkees steve sarkeesian i mean as
an offensive coordinator
loves dialing up double moves and i
don't think there's another receiving
group in the country
is good at running them devonte smith
catches at least one double move
td a week jaylen model was doing it
before john metchi
uh the canadian from brampton ontario
outside he's catching a post for a
touchdown every week so
so mac jones has to deal with it more
than a lot of other people but as a
quarterback when you're back there
you know you're trying to play fast and
you're trying to get your read and take
your steps and look downfield and
decipher decipher the coverage
and try to really quickly get a read on
where your receiver is and where his
body position is in relation to
the closest offender to him you look
down there and you see that he's got him
beat by four or five yards
and you tighten up and you think oh god
you know i got to make this perfect and
that's
oftentimes when it's tight coverage
that's when as a quarterback you can
really just let it rip
um you know throw a fastball uh without
overthinking it and so you know for mac
jones maybe that makes the season even
more impressive he's made a lot of very
tough
wide open throws this year it's amazing
all right let's
handicap what's going to happen this
weekend um i'll give you just some of my
thoughts or some of the information that
i've uh
gathered here notre dame would if notre
dame would lose
the way alabama beat texas a m maybe
i'm told by a source with the committee
that they could they could
lose their way out of the final four if
clemson would lose a close game
they probably would still have a hard
time staying in but i don't believe that
because they love those shiny objects
they want to have trevor lawrence in
there
and florida if florida beats alabama
alabama we know is still staying in
can florida get in so wherever you want
to go with that whatever topic you want
to dive into
if you have uh you know something uh to
the concert
so i i would say bam is a lot to be in i
think with florida losing to lsu last
week in north carolina smashing miami i
now think notre dame's in i kind of
thought like you
last week i thought well if notre dame
goes out and they get blown out by
clemson
there's a possibility that they could
get left out you gotta remember in 2017
georgia got beat by uh auburn by
i think it was 23 points they still got
in as a one loss team
i think with with notre dame's resume
unc is a team the committee really likes
they certainly look great against miami
last week and they've beaten clemson
already
i think you could take a one loss notre
dame resume and put it up against a 6-0
ohio state
um or a uh or even an 8-1 texas a
m whose best win would be the gators who
by the way after this weekend might be a
three loss team
clemson if they lose the notre dame
clemson game to me is really the kind of
the interesting story in this because
if notre dame wins clemson loses you've
got a two loss clemson that's lost twice
to the number two team in the country
what does that look like against say an
8-1 texas a m
clemson's resume if they lose wouldn't
necessarily be great
not just being a two loss team and we've
never seen a two-last team get in
their best win is 18 miami
there's only two teams on clemson's uh
schedule
pittsburgh and boston college who
currently have winning records outside
of
of miami so it's not as strong as you
potentially like i do agree
i think people think that with trevor
lawrence on the field if people expect
them to win that game
if notre dame loses this weekend do they
fall from two to three
and then does the committee rematch
clemson and notre dame for a third time
is that something is that something that
the committee would talk about do we
really want to see this again
what if it's a close game um and you say
well
notre dame won the first in double ot
clemson won the second yeah
let's let's let him do it again um or d
would they would they move notre dame
down purposely to four and maybe ohio
state up to avoid that rematch
there's another possibility i mean texas
a m if notre dame wins could slide into
number four
and now you've got that bama texas a m
rematch and you mentioned they got beat
by 28 points the first time so there are
rematch scenarios very alive this
weekend be interesting to see how the
committee decides to
to play that they're not supposed to
factor that into their their discussion
with respect to
who's number one two three and four but
it's it seems like it's common sense and
it's human instinct just to have to
at least factor that in and consider it
yeah i said it's a tv
show and i i get criticized but
you know they they want the four best
schools they want the biggest fan bases
they want eyeballs on this
a m if a m had johnny manziel jesse
we would be talking about them in a
different way
we don't know texas a m we know we know
their coach and that's it they have a
quality team we all know that
iowa state has more shiny objects than a
m does
i think as far as talent goes skill
position guys uh usc if usc had been in
the conversation the last couple of
years
we would look at them differently this
year so
i i just don't know what the process is
that's a fair
process and maybe i'm being naive every
other sport
they want parody you know the nfl
wants parody they want to help you if
you're bad the next year they give you
an easier schedule baseball like they
will give you the number one pick
college football doesn't want parody
here so
as we move down the road here next five
years
like what does college football look
like if it looks any different than it
does now
you know it's it's you know we kind of
you know go into every year
and and we sort of have our expectation
level and you know
and this year was no different even with
the pandemic and shortened season for
some conferences i think
people still expect bama they still
expect clemson they still expect ohio
state and then it's kind of like hey who
else
yeah who else is going to get in uh with
the way recruiting is going today it's
like the rich keep getting richer
and and you got to give those those
schools credit i mean they
there's not a lot of drop off at
quarterback i think that that's been one
of the big factors this year
for a lot of these these programs and
their continued success
you know the the texas a m thing i think
is interesting because the committees
respected them the entire time
i think that win against the gators has
stood out in the committee's mind
uh they've been sitting there at number
five i think every college football
playoff ranking they're right there
they need help they need notre dame to
win they need alabama to win so they can
say their worst losses against the
number one ranked team but
you're right i mean you know maybe not
the not the headliners
kellen mons very quietly had a very good
year he's been inconsistent throughout
his career
18 tds this season only two picks they
run the ball i'd argue this is the best
jimbo fisher's called plays on offense
at any point his collegiate career even
better than when he was
at florida state simply because they had
their best receiver opt out at the start
of the year they had another key
receiver get hurt in that game against
florida and he's had to kind of scheme
guys open
they're a dominant defense they're a
really good team if texas a m gets in
because clemson loses
i don't have a problem with it but you
know i think that notre dame clemson
game the acc title game i think
will go a long way in kind of
determining you know the order of what
we see one through four
ohio state just win and you're in like
it doesn't matter if it's
by one or by you know 25
i i hesitate to say by one i i think
they need to go out and dominate
um and and listen if they do that then
then i think they're absolutely in
uh at six to no they've been a dominant
team that's been in control
um of their games this year even in the
close loss against indiana they were
winning that game 35-7
until it started getting weird and
justin fields had his worst game
throwing the ball throwing three picks
um in that game but you know the
committee loves indiana they love
northwestern from a resume standpoint
those would be good wins for ohio state
and you know a lot of there's a lot of
detractors saying well you only played
six games
if the committee felt like ohio state
was quote unquote comparable
maybe to a two loss clemson or a one
loss texas a m then maybe you take the
amount of games played
as a tiebreaker ohio state would have
the big ten championship which the
committee is supposed to use as a
tiebreaker
a two loss clemson and texas a m
wouldn't have that so that would be an
interesting discussion as well but
i think if you're ryan day in ohio state
i think if you win that game
convincingly like they're expected to
then i think ohio state's in the playoff
thank you jesse we appreciate your time
happy holidays
and uh we'll be watching coming up this
weekend
you got it man thanks for thank
everybody that's uh jesse palmer espn
college football analyst and uh they'll
recap
uh this weekend's action the college
football playoff selection day
college football the selection show will
be noon eastern this sunday
on espn we'll